give it up next for led Chu
the good thing about being different in
a town like this is that no one expects
you to be like them I'm 17 I live in
square hamish with my dad I run a
business writing essays for people I
guess I just never thought I'd need
anyone else $10 for three pages no I'm
not trying to cheat what's this alert
maybe you can make me sound smart
dear aster Florence I'm in love with you
[Music]
these hallways are we murder I'm Alisha
yeah I know
[Music]
you want a letter about love all right
your letter about love hey she wrote
back we can do this ask him to hang off
:
you message me yup
conversation is like ping-pong I hit one
and then you where were you born in
school hey Mitch what do you like about
Squamish I've never been anywhere else
mine either
what do you like about asked her she's
pretty and smart
what else could I like about her I don't
know how her eyes are cried in neighbors
how you can live in an ocean of her
thoughts and she really knows
I'm so stupid I just meant you like a
sir
hey it would suck to have to pretend to
be not you your whole life an account no
wait
who you thought you - what
[Music]
you know what it's like to finally meet
someone your age who gets you
it's not finding your perfect half
it's the trying and reaching and failing
I know you don't see her
who she is
she could be
[Music]